my name is danny burke for the score
esports one thing that we have in common
with pro players
is our love of skins sometimes though
skins can threaten the very
competitive integrity of a game the
reasons for this
can vary from the relatable to the quite
frankly
ridiculous you'll see what i mean these
are the top 10
banned skins in esports
starting off our list at number 10 is
elementalist
looks fair warning i'm testing the
limits of my powers today
now i haven't got a problem with this
skin except for the fact that it costs
25
the problem that pros have with it
though is that some of her animations
just look
way too similar oh what the [ __ ] i
didn't even know that was the
i didn't even know that was the lux cube
that's why their skin's banned in uh
competitive what the [ __ ] is that
i've been playing league for quite a
while now and even i can't tell the
difference between
her bind and her slow and i like knowing
if i'm about to be stuck in place and
getting a giant
laser shove down my throat it's nice to
know you know
taking number nine on our list are all
of cs goes player skins
which were banned within days of being
released
this game they need to fix it operation
shattered web gave cs go players
agent skins for their t and ct models
for the first time
ever now the problem is that those skins
and many surfaces
in cs go blended together even better
than
ketchup and mayo yes i have mixed those
together don't judge me
anyway it was almost impossible to see
your enemies in certain spots on certain
maps
if they were using the agent's skins
when i first saw this i saw a screenshot
something like this and i was like
there's no way
it took me like five seconds to spot the
guy he blends
in so well it became a bit of a meme
back in november 2019
as players were getting killed by what
essentially looked like
walls maybe a little bit okay clear
graveyard
a little bit there's literally no one
here
well yes there is he looks like a flower
pot
how can this be a thing esl esea
and others had to either remove the
shattered web skins from pro play
or remove the pros themselves they went
with the skins
good move coming in at number eight we
have
our mika's default costume now i've
never been banned from the public's eye
for being too
sexy but that's exactly what happened at
evo 2016.
at first everything seemed fairly normal
with fudo comfortably taking his first
match
he moves on a winner's final of evil
however unbeknown to fans fudo received
a message from the officials
that there was a problem he had to
change his costume
espn was broadcasting the tournament and
daddy disney
felt that mika's bare butt was a little
too hot for daytime tv
so they asked evo's toes to make fudo
switch skins
now they needed to grab a translator to
tell him all that
which really makes me wonder how do you
say
bro that costume is going to corrupt the
youth of america in japanese
moving on to number 7 now we have gills
pyron costume from street fighter 5.
in march 2020 the capcom pro tour
removed a
whole bunch of costumes from competitive
play the players have been complaining
about
for quite a while and gil's pyron
costume was one of
the worst offenders this is probably one
of the most distracting costumes in the
whole game
he had a heat distortion effect that
rippled over him and made it impossible
to consistently punish his buttons
his flames concealed his ex moves and
the fact that he was
constantly on fire made it really hard
to tell when characters like dow sim and
poison
actually lit him on fire you'd think it
couldn't get worse than this
but somehow it does coming in at number
six now we have
sieges ember eye skins just like csgo's
shattered web agent skins
these skins let siege players go full
predator
on certain parts of some maps but
somehow
it got way worse you blend in with walls
and you don't know what operator you're
playing against
and it's like every character pretty
much they're 50
like every character it didn't take long
for players to start complaining about
its visibility issues
and g2 then the best siege team in the
world even went all in to make sure they
had the
competitive edge e2 gave us the money to
buy this skin
as a business expense because it was
necessary to win secure the bomb they
paid
us money to buy the ember ice cream
eventually esl brought the ban hammer
down on ember rise
it only terrorized pro league for about
six weeks but i'm sure it will stay with
pengu for
a lot longer than that
moving on to number five now we have
sweet tooth soul
from smite yes you heard it smite
the game you either forget to love or
love to forget
by the way it doesn't get talked about
enough in my books this skin may look
too sweet to cause any harm but
don't let the bubbles fool you in april
2020 smite banned sweet
tooth sold because her visual effects
particle effects
and audio cues everything about her
basically was
and i quote too intense i don't think
you're ready
for this jelly
while the devs did eventually tone it
down and unban her
the damage to many people's eardrums was
already done
next up at number four now we have i
blitzcrank
the time of man has come to an end
this sleek skin quickly proved to be a
fan favorite
after its release in 2013. it kinda
looks to me like if
apple made steam golems it all came down
to his cue
rocket grab the wire connecting
blitzcrank's arms to his body
is considerably more difficult to see
than in the base skin
it was already tilting enough when you
get hit by it but somehow
riot made it even worse however many
skins like i blitzcrank did receive some
updates but still have minor
discrepancies
that can't really be fully solved
without completely changing the skin
next up at number three we have magneto
king
of spain that's magneto but not in the
costume i want to talk about
you see the magneto king of spain story
goes way back
to 2005 when marvel used this portrait
of king juan carlos of spain as a design
for the master of magnetism here's that
comic depiction
and here's king carlos's portrait see
the resemblance
well the monarchy certainly did and
decided to sue
marvel i sacrificed for mutant kind
lawyers and this sacrifice fast forward
to 2012
and capcom tried to stick the same
outfit into ultimate marvel vs capcom 3
as a costume for magneto to the surprise
of absolutely nobody
the royal family once again threatened
legal action and a costume was removed
from the game
the dream is dead
moving on to number two we have the
frankly embarrassing saga
of nix a swing from laxing but he's got
five seconds to find the three remaining
members of disrupt
and he's not getting past that shotgun
blast of knicks at all sitting on the
defuser
yes he's a player we'll get to the skins
trust me
nick's caused a real stir during stage
one of the rainbow six
nal when he broke the no skins rule not
once
not twice but three times he played buck
mira and mute and use band operator
skins each time
uh like just don't have the skins on i
don't know like
once or twice i can make sense but like
i'd be surprised if they were calling
that many like out of the blue plays to
where they had to like change skins
uh he was saying that like casper the
friendly ghost was on his pc
changing everything so nix's team lost
the game
and he was quick to apologize on twitter
for the mistake stating that his pc
had loaded an old cloud save and somehow
that made him use a bunch of illegal
skins
now i believe him but that does sound a
bit like the
dog ate my homework of esports excuses
and finally taking the number one spot
on our list we have
just a car syndra syndra's big balls of
energy
are usually purple that's not a medical
condition
that's how they're meant to be but her
justicar syndra skin changed things by
making her magic orbs
a translucent white color see absolute
control as cool as it looks many players
found the lighter orbs difficult to see
and if you can't keep track of her balls
you'd run the risk of being smashed to
death by them sacred laid down orbs
there's the holds on the dog
now oh and a knife baker with the
blaze under knock knee that is faker
while riot has never officially banned
this skin from pro play
it has been suspiciously absent for
quite a while now
and many amateur leagues have publicly
banned just a car syndra over the years
well there you have it guys there is
something about banned skins that just
sort of
makes me want them even more you know
luckily
for me though i'll never have to worry
about that because i'm not a pro
that's just another reason why i chose
not to be a pro yeah chose
it was totally a choice because of the
skins yeah
and guys if you made it to the end of
the video that means you can at least
bear my british accent which is probably
a good thing and
even better news there's more videos on
the way so please
make sure you are subscribed leave this
video a like and i'll see you all in the
next one